type of cancer that we're talking about
this morning colon cancer Brazilian
soccer Legend Pele recently lost his
battle to this disease it is much more
common than you might think it is colon
cancer awareness month and we want to
arm you with knowledge to protect
yourself Candace Charles joining us live
in studio with what you need to know and
uh Candace where first of all where are
you what is that well well Heather I
have brought my friend with me Colleen
Colleen actually it was a Nevada cancer
Coalition that brought it now colon
cancer or colorectal cancer really is
the second leading cause of cancer death
among men and women combined I can't
believe that but it really is true but
it's preventable and treatable if you
get screened early so get screened
that's the number one thing I want to
tell you and I have jorgeous here with
me from Nevada cancer Coalition tell us
a little bit about the screening yeah so
people should be screening at the age of
45. if they do have family history you
definitely want to go let your primary
care provider now so you might be doing
your tests early there are different
test testing methods the basic one is
for sure the colonoscopy which is good
for 10 years if you do have something
going on you'll have to do it every five
years but there are still at home stool
tests that you can do so it's more
convenient for people to do that all
right coming up we'll talk a little bit
more about the screenings but I want to
tell you a little bit more about Colleen
here what exactly is this huge thing
George well we have Colleen here which
shows all the different types of uh
things that's going on with your colon
so we have like the normal colon tissue
you know what this should be the normal
then we have like the polyps that could
be found then we have uh
colorectal cancer it is Progressive kind
of through this entire huge inflatable
colon that is amazing George this is a
great way to teach folks and you guys
can find them I'm sure throughout the
state thank you so much for all the work
you're doing in the community we really
appreciate it now if you want to know a
little bit more about Colleen here or
about colon cancer or even about the
Nevada Coalition cancer Coalition excuse
me you can go to our website newsnow.com
for now live in studio I'm Candice
Charles 8 News Now a valuable tool there
for a great lesson uh thank you so much
Candace it's uh good to see it kind of
in enlarged there